in this video i'm going to teach you a
key consulting methodology that is being
used by
almost all management consulting firms
including mbb consulting firms like bcg
or bain but the best
thing is you do not need to work in
consulting to make use of this approach
it is helpful in whatever context you
operate and if you are
in a position to solve problems for your
employer
in today's video i'm talking about the
theory and practice of hypothesis
driven problem solving and trust me guys
this is really crucial it is one of the
most
important concepts so sit tight listen
until the end because in the end i'm
going to give you some nice
practical tips as well and let's do this
together welcome to another coffee break
here on this channel with me
my name is heinrich and on my channel
firm learning i want to help you to
become successful
in the first years of your career as you
know i started my own consulting career
at accenture i worked for the company
during my university studies and then
after university i
joined mckinsey and spent six years with
the firm in the end
serving as a project lead so let's start
by better understanding what
hypothesis-based consulting actually is
and i have a couple of slides prepared
for you guys so let's jump into it
so what is hypothesis based problem
solving so it is an approach to write a
project into tasks it is a way of
thinking
an approach to define the project scope
and outcome a prerequisite to focus data
collection and analysis and approach to
solve
unstructured and complex problems so
hope this already gives you the
impression and helps you to understand
that hypothesis based
problem solving is really at the core of
most consulting projects but let's get a
little bit more tangible and to me it is
important to stress that this
is not only a process that is strictly
limited to consulting but you can pretty
much use and apply it to
every other business problem that you
have so what do we see here and indeed
it always starts with a business problem
there's a challenge that management of
your company is facing
maybe profits are down maybe costs are
exploding in a specific business area
and here now often this is a situation
where companies then engage a
consultancy to help them figure out the
solution or they also might ask an
internal team to look into it and to
come up with solutions
and now to move from the problem to the
solution
you will need to have facts you will
need to conduct analysis and of course
in this way from problem to solution
you often already have some facts there
are some things
that you already know but of course
there are gaps there are things that you
do
not yet know and that would be required
to really verify a solution just come up
with it in the first place
and now what many young graduates also
more unexperienced business
professionals will do is well they will
say
until i have closed these gaps until
i've really
looked at everything until i really did
my thorough research
no way i can come up with a solution
until i did all of this right
and this my friends is not the way how
you should operate in the business world
this is more of an academic approach
you need to look into everything you do
all your research
and then maybe in the very end you can
come up with a solution
but and you will already know this if
you have watched my video on top down
communication that i will link now here
somewhere above the key to being
successful in business is always already
having some kind of
goal some key message some key result
already in your head it is important to
very early on in the process to have a
hypothesis based
solution in your mind for the problem
that you are now
testing and analyzing for instead of not
starting with
nothing and needing to look at
everything before you can come up with
the solution so indeed what you will do
when you follow this hypothesis driven
problem-solving approach is that from
day one
you close the gaps with hypothesis so
when you are faced with a business
problem now before starting to look into
anything before starting to conduct any
analysis at all
ask yourself what do i already know and
now what are the likely hypothesis that
you can make and based on that what is
your day one
answer to the project once you've
established such an hypothesized
solution
then based on that you cannot test it
you can now refine it and to an
iterative way come to a better solution
so let's look into a tangible example
let's imagine there is a mobile payment
service provider who wants to
enter the brazilian market and as a
consultant on day one maybe you sit
together with your team maybe there is a
more senior guy in the room a partner
some experts from the clients and just
sit together and you ask yourself okay
what is my hypothesis what the answer
should be
in which country the market entry is
recommended now based on this very first
session on day one you apologize
for key factors first the growth so you
want to be
in the market with the highest growth
second the affinity to mobile payment
so which markets are more effie into
mobile payments than others third the
attractiveness of the offering so for
which countries do you have an
attractive offering
and then fourth where is competition
very small and little competition so
these are the factors that you believe
are relevant and not from your
hypothesis from your first knowledge
that you already have you believe that
brazil indeed might be a good fit due to
these factors but now of course this is
only the start and now indeed you need
to collect the data you need to look
into
it and understand and verify whether
this is actually the case or not so now
you do conduct the research and now you
indeed find that brazil
at least in terms of the market size
maybe not the growth but in terms of the
size it is very attractive because it
has a population
of 200 million people and all these
numbers are just made up and on top of
that brazilians are also very open and
interested in mobile payment
making it very interesting as well
because the affinity is quite high maybe
you were also
able to confirm that actually your
product offering is attractive to
brazilian customers
though in the end you came to the
conclusion that no in brazil
there is actually a lot of competition
there isn't little competition so you
see that now you need to cut out the
point of little competition
because you were not able to verify the
hypothesis but still based on these
three factors so now you were
able to confirm you still feel confident
in making the recommendation that the
mobile payment service provider should
indeed
enter the brazilian market for these
three reasons
now i hope that you already can
understand why this hypothesis driven
approach
is very helpful because on day one you
are asking yourself okay what would it
mean for a country to be an attractive
target for market entry
this now enables you to give a day one
answer so back to the top-down
communication approach if now the ceo
walks in
on day one and asks you what your
current status where do you stand with
the project you can already give a very
first hypothesis without having looked
into any data
at all and now once you move to the next
stage to the data analysis stage now you
do not need to look at
everything right the only things that
you need to look at are your hypothesis
and try to verify or falsify your
hypothesis
because you already know if you came up
with a good and logical structure so now
let's break it down even further
how would this really look like and
indeed at some point management will
confront you with an objective so you
need to ask yourself okay what does
management actually want to achieve
next step is to translate these
management objectives into your project
objectives so again it doesn't matter if
you're a consultant or just an internal
team working on it ask yourself
what does your specific project really
needs to accomplish
then you're breaking down the project
into its individual
sub-parts into its key drivers different
consulting firms give different names to
this
some like to call it modules others like
to call it
work streams others just project areas
but you often like to break it down into
different sub-areas that are relevant
and then often you staff
every team member on one of these key
areas or maybe one team member also
addresses two of these key drivers but
these are kind of the key areas that you
look at
that you can structure the project in
and here now of course
the mesi principle is super important i
talked about this principle in another
video i will link it also somewhere
above here the mesi principle is now the
principle that you need to apply
when you now break down the overall
project into its sub-components now once
you have defined the key drivers that
will lead you to a result
now is the time when you need to come up
with the hypothesis and then once you've
noted down your hypothesis and of course
some things you might already know right
but for the things that you do not know
yet
ask yourself what are the key questions
what are the analysis that i need to do
now in order to falsify
or to verify my hypothesis because from
this you will know exactly what analysis
do you need to do this will also tell
you what data you need to collect so
this
really is now your road map for the
project in order to get to the objective
where you want to get it and in the
sense now hope that you recognize this
two-tiered
structure this two-tiered approach of
this hypothesis-based problem solving so
first you structure
the problem this is really crucial and
it's an essential part of the whole
problem solving process
and this is also why consulting firms
put so much emphasis
on getting the structure right on coming
up with messy structures
because of course if you mess this up
then like your whole and end of the
structure will be messed up and you will
not get to the right results so once
you've completed your structure and you
defined all your required analysis this
is then when you move to the second
phase of your work and this is really
the whole analytical work and based on
these facts that you collected of course
you will find some hypothesis to be true
so you verified them but some other
hypothesis now you need to reject you
will not find them to be true and in
this sense now this is an iterative
process that whenever you falsify an
hypothesis you need to ask yourself
whether the conclusions that you
hypothesized now are still
valid so if i take this hypothesis away
can i still defend
my conclusion or do i need to iterate
and change it revise my hypothesis
conduct some new analysis and then
review and update my conclusions and
recommendations based on that i hope
this video was insightful if you took
any value out of this video at all
please hit the like button
for the youtube algorithm and also
subscribe to my channel to stay up to
date on all my content i release weekly
videos every saturday in addition if you
really want to help me out with the
youtube algorithm please
leave a comment below in the comment
section this really helps me and of
course you can ask me whatever question
you still might have and i'm happy to
answer every single question that you
have if you want to see even more
content from me follow me on my
instagram my handle is firm learning
and i also have a mailing list you can
sign up to that there's a link
in the video description below i now
want to take a moment to say thank you
to all the members of this channel thank
you so much guys you're really making a
difference for me and supporting me and
running this channel and if you want to
become a members way
there's a join button next to the
subscribe button if you hit it you get
all the details and you will get access
to some member
only perks if you become a member again
thank you so much for watching i really
appreciate it my name is heinrich and
next saturday i will be back with
another video for you guys
looking forward to that and until then
good weekend to all of you